It's a moving theory.I'm a mob voice
actor.It seems that from now on, Take-kun will be able to eat milk-based foods that he likes
.
Yes, it's
delicious.
Well, after I ate this, it was all over No. 2
Feeling spoiled Japanese
Melting
cheeks It
's very similar to the day of the oven, is
n't it?
I don't
have it I don't have it I
'm at a loss because all the delicious things come.
Manic water
Well, this kind of sweetness is hard to come by in Japan It's a
little more twitter hm
me Oh cheese cracker Wow
2 patterns
yeah
hm I can put it in either way
Ann
I
wonder if this is different 5
[Music]
Somehow, there are three things in it I think it's someone's mistake
Everyone, the
header is different, isn't it
? ー
b Fe b
9 minutes
Do
you have the beans ready?
When I first heard about the project, people really didn't eat it.  I thought that it would come out with a taste like
that, so I
was surprised that it was generally delicious. I thought that America is kind.